hi guys marry somebody no no no you know
your life is different now I'm here with
Miranda sing yeah it's the end of 2017
ain't gone if you have one word to
describe this year for yourself and the
world what would it be one for me
incredible incredible one for the world
sucks to be you
the great word I thought because Miranda
is just a genius in a lot of ways and
really a trendsetter in so many other
ways that she and I would go through
some predictions for 2018 I know
everything that's gonna happen but I
have some categories for us to go
through and just to hear your thoughts
on what do you think it's gonna happen
in each of these scenarios for 2018 okay
easy peasy what do you think it's gonna
be the main thing that happens on
YouTube for 2018 I already know okay I
know it's gonna be me so I will be the
most popular as YouTube are also on top
of that there's something that's really
cool that I really hope will start to
become really trendy it's amazing and
it's better than any other trend it's
better than any other thing that's ever
happened on YouTube it's this thing
called slime no one knows about it yet
true but I think it deserves more
attention on the anime I was I saying
2018 you and Logan Paul are gonna be a
big yeah we're gonna date it's gonna be
a lot of cochise david dobrik situation
yeah well I'm also going to take David
from lines I'm gonna have both of those
right what about Jake Paul um I don't
know who that is what do you think it's
gonna be the new popular social media
platform we have like Instagram stories
I know what it is there's gonna be this
epic new platform that's gonna blow
minds nice things
have you used myspace before yes you
know how many email selfies I have they
don't know what they were talking about
no not at all it's vintage
I've heard that Wilden LinkedIn or
Friendster no I've never dabbled in
LinkedIn I get a lot of emails from
I was only sliding up in my DN I mean
you know it's like won't bad I'm like
not today doing what do you think in
2018 either online or in the
entertainment industry is gonna be the
biggest scandal when I steal David from
Liza that will be a bigger than a huge
scandal I also think all the Kardashians
are gonna be pregnant with each other's
babies
I feel like Rosie O'Donnell is gonna be
back oh my gosh don't be my dream
because I always wanted a Koosh ball
that's another thing that they don't
really probably know about if you don't
know what a Koosh ball is get out of
town but I don't know that's gonna be
scandal that's gonna be like a good
thing I think maybe this can OSI
O'Donnell and Donald Trump will start
dating or they're gonna do like a
celebrity boxing match that will be
pretty good who's gonna have a major
breakthrough
is there an artist or a performer or a
person that you think is really gonna
break through and start kind of getting
recognition cardi B is already having
its major breakthrough of all 2007 she
needs to clean up for a language film
she's seeing lots of am horns I think
the most biggest breakthrough will be a
baby because we have been getting
younger and younger on who who gets
popular yeah have you seen the music
please so I'm thinking it will be when
the Kardashian babies oh is that one of
the O's a perhaps partner if you have a
baby
oh no no are you pregnant no no no sure
pretty sure because that baby could grow
many famous that could be a great
business strategy for me maybe I'll get
pregnant if I get married fast enough to
the don't want twins okay what do you
think is gonna be the fashion trend in
2018 well I've been saying the pageants
I know this yeah red pants with striped
shirts I was doing four years and then
it got really popular yeah I think tax
ones oh okay or capes in interesting
places
oh they're number on your next like a
buck came another looking for a chest
ski not talking I want to see yet more
innovation in the world of sweatpants as
Pam
I think you wear sweatpants amazingly
and you have also really leaned in and
encouraged that trend in the last few
years
thank you can people still get your
sofas yes they can okay so what do you
think is going to be the word or phrase
that's most popular in 2018 school no no
yo just 9 hey what a Miranda oh cool
I got a new bar oh good make it rain
hashtag small that'd be good okay what
do you think is gonna be the fidgets
thinner replacement in 2018 pop song
kids fidget yeah pops like at fidgets
the new ones break really easily so it'd
be friends who can shatters first yeah
how many phones can you shatter in the
shortest period of time let's figure out
what we think is gonna happen for you
and for me in 2018 the big moment well I
think I'm gonna get really famous on my
prediction for you is that there's gonna
be Miranda sings the musical okay on
Broadway
okay in New York City pain I think it's
gonna be big I think for you it will be
grace helbig the musical on Broadway I
just thought of that also I think you're
gonna get pregnant I really hope so like
immediately first thing pregnancy
exactly happening right on the dawn you
might get married get ring it right away
get bring it and then you're like all
the plans I had going out the window now
I'm doing with this baby no health
insurance anymore you know my name in
the income anymore YouTube's done all
the plans you are doing for money gone
yeah and it's just all about the baby
the miracle okay baby that's a very
specific prediction we'll see what
happens
I hope keep fingers crossed going or
dumb like that bellows the king chin so
you can find out when it happened yeah I
didn't see announcements well on that
note I think we've made enough
predictions for 2018 Miranda thank you
so much Colonel Walker giving us all the
words of wisdom and makes you guys go
check out Miranda's chat
because in her grand scheme of me
getting pregnant she helped me find a
date for her New Year's party via a
tinder she created a tinder profile for
me and we talked to a lot of actual
people on tinder oh my god
the link will be in description box
we'll go check that out and I guess
enjoy the rest of 2017 while you can
yeah hopefully it's over now I don't
know imagine tiny little games I think
those are just toenails actually true
could be but what if they were fabric
that's a talking that's a joke a good